gérard vespière fondateurs du web
magazine le monde décrypté
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france sont sait peu de
choses mais qu'est ce qu'on s'est un peu
de cet accord conclu entre pékin et
téhéran
d'abord c'est le sentiment que l'on peut
avoir c'est un accord comme on dirait en
politique intérieure
un accord d'appareils 10 par le pouvoir
chinois et le pouvoir iranien
je veux faire référence à un homme un
peu étonnant qui s'appelle monsieur
ahmadinejad qui a déja diné quelques
années que cet accord se réalisait mais
sans aucune implication de la population
iranienne donc voilà le sentiment qui
peut y avoir à l'intérieur du pays
en iran donc le contenu le contenu il
est économique il est dans le domaine
des transports et dans le domaine des
facilités portuaires ou peut-être même
dans l'acquisition d'un port puisque là
bien sûr il y à toutes les architectures
un des routes de la soie chinoise indé
nouvelle route de la soie vert vers
l'europe
donc voilà la l'iran était effectivement
un et la chine sont des partenaires
économiques fort à l'iran a fourni
beaucoup de pétrole à la chine pendant
de nombreuses années beaucoup moins
maintenant et il ya depuis quelques
années une diminution paradoxalement de
leur commerce réciproque puisque les
échanges sont tombés d'un tiers depuis
2018 donc voyez vous tout n'est pas
forcément rose
il était en discussion depuis plusieurs
années cet accord vous venez un peu de
l'évoquer mais pour qu'on comprenne bien
qu'est-ce qui a vraiment accélérer la
signature de cet accord hier a accéléré
à partir du moment où vous avez des
négociations qui durent reprenant
plusieurs années il ya forcément un
moment fois une rupture soit un accord
donc je pense pas qu'il y ait
d'accélération mais comme l'ont dit les
ennemis de mes ennemis sont mes amis
donc il ya une tension entre les
etats-unis et la chine les etats-unis et
l'iran donc l'iran et la chine se
rapproche puisque ils ont un ennemi
commun qui sont les états unis donc je
pense que
il y a peut-être là un regard à apporter
à l'iran est quand même dans une
situation économique très très très
difficile une situation sociale aussi
très difficile par le chômage par la
baisse du niveau de vie
donc elle a besoin de support monétaire
et financier
ati peut lui en donner à ses voisins la
turquie n'ont pas vraiment à un allié
aussi potentiel à la russie mais c'est
pas forcément la façon d'opérer de la
russie donc il y dresse effectivement le
grand éloignement de la de la chine a
pour éventuellement aider à la situation
économique difficile de l'iran qui fait
face dans quelques mois à des élections
présidentielles qui peuvent continuer à
radicaliser le régime selon vous lequel
de ces deux pays a lâché nous lirons
elle a le plus à gagner dans cet accord
de coopération à d'un point de vue
marginal c'est l'iran puisque l'iran est
effectivement dans la situation qu'on
viennent d'écrire
donc elle a besoin d'argent elle a
besoin d'accords elle a besoin sur le
plan de l'image internationale
puisqu'elle est un peu rejetés
à part la communauté européenne rejetée
par les états unis
donc elle veut se tourner vers à un
autre regard celui de de pékin donc
effectivement un l'iran est demandeuse
de support et dette et alors comment est
perçu cet accord du côté des américains
alors que se profilent de nouvelles
discussions avec téhéran pour évoquer un
éventuel retour des etats unis dans le
cadre de l'accord sur son programme
nucléaire
alors là il ya question du temps à quand
on regarde l'accord son terme est un
accord stratégique sur 25 ans et je
crois que toute la subtile une des
éléments des éléments de subtilité tient
dans cette expression cette période
on essaye de faire du temps du côté
iranien un allié on y sent voyez vous on
a des perspectives de long terme alors
que en iran vis-à-vis du régime
le temps est l'ennemi il y à des
mouvements sociaux importants
donc il y à des élections à venir
comment la situation va évoluer
on ne sait pas donc vis-à-vis des
etats-unis il ya effectivement une
opportunité dire voyez vous nous avons
un nouvel allié donc ça peut être un
poids vis-à-vis de négociations avec les
états unis
mais n'oublions pas qu'il y a deux ans
les chinois ont dit à téhéran ah si vous
soit vous sortez la nécessité de sortir
de l'accord il faudra bien réfléchir
préalablement merci beaucoup pour votre
éclairage gérer un vestiaire je rappelle
que sept fondateurs du web magazine le
monde décrypté